.
* Klagender, wortloser Frauengesang *
Kennst du deinen Berg?
- Wolltest du dich einreihen?
Ich war lange nicht mehr so froh,
diesen verdammten Hügel zu sehen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Jubelruf *
Danke vielmals.
- Das war gut.
Super.
Merci. Danke.
David, danke für alles.
- Merci.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Frankreich, Mont-Blanc-Gebiet.
Sieben Menschen sind aufgebrochen,
um sich einen Traum zu erfüllen.
Es ist ihr erster Tag
auf der berühmten Haute Route,
einer Skitour quer durch die Alpen,
von Chamonix nach Zermatt.
80 km, 7'000 Höhenmeter -
in sechs Tagen von Hütte zu Hütte.
Gut, packt mal die Felle weg!
Ihr könnt auch reinkommen.
Die Gruppe
sieht sich heute zum ersten Mal.
Mit dabei: Olympiasiegerin und ehema-
lige Weltcupfahrerin Dominique Gisin
sowie ihre frühere Skirennfahr-
kollegin Fränzi Aufdenblatten.
Vielleicht Severin.
David Fasel ist ihr Bergführer,
zusammen mit Bruno Jelk,
dem ehemaligen Rettungschef
von Zermatt.
Auch dabei:
der CEO der Allianz-Gruppe Schweiz,
ein Heilpädagoge,
eine Tochter mit ihrem Vater
und eine junge Frau, die in Gedenken
an ihre verstorbene Mutter
auf der Tour dabei ist.
Ich war lange nicht mehr
in einem Schullager.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Die Haute Route
durch die höchsten Berge der Alpen -
ein Mythos auf der ganzen Welt.
An ihrem ersten gemeinsamen Abend
in der Hütte lernen sie sich kennen.
Alle sind gespannt,
mit wem sie unterwegs sind.
Ich arbeite 80 % bei Swisscom.
Nebenher studiere ich Wirtschaft.
Und ich habe Familie in Zermatt,
meinen Freund in Brig,
ich wohne in Bern und ...
Das alles mit den schönen Ver-
pflichtungen meines früheren Lebens.
Ja, vielleicht mal Zeit haben,
ein wenig über mich
und das Leben nachdenken.
Wenn man mal am Anschlag ist, kommen
vielleicht all die Sachen raus,
die man im Alltag
gar nicht so weit kommen lässt.
Ich habe auch schon vor einer Weile
mit Skifahren aufgehört.
Im Moment studiere ich Physik
an der ETH Zürich.
Ich befinde mich im Endspurt
meiner Berufspilotenausbildung.
Das ist
eine meiner Langzeitleidenschaften.
Ich meine, was Fränzi gesagt hat,
ist bei mir schon auch ein Thema.
Für mich ist es
auch immer Lebensqualität,
sich mal eine Woche zu nehmen -
sei das auf der Haute Route
oder eine Woche Windsurfen.
Das ist für mich auch wichtig.
Ich habe nach 30 Jahren Arbeit
an einer Schule
die Entscheidung getroffen,
zu kündigen.
Ich höre dort mit der Arbeit auf
und versuche,
mich selbstständig zu machen.
Und damit habe ich mich
auch entschieden, mutiger zu werden.
Ich habe mich bis jetzt nicht so
als mutigen Menschen erlebt.
Ich habe jetzt also
diese Entscheidung getroffen,
und die Entscheidung, auf die Haute
Route zu gehen, hat damit zu tun.
Bei mir war die zeitliche
Verfügbarkeit ein Hindernis, also:
Kann ich mich einfach für eine Woche
aus dem Büro verabschieden?
Wir haben diese Woche ...
Morgen haben wir eine
Verwaltungsratssitzung dieser Firma,
übermorgen ist
eine Geschäftsleitungssitzung usw.
Ich musste mich organisieren,
also Stellvertreter besorgen -
oder solche, die mir einfach helfen,
diese Zeit zu überbrücken.
Das ist mir gelungen, und darum
habe ich definitiv zugesagt.
Ich bin alleinerziehende Mutter
von zwei kleinen Jungs -
sie sind dreieinhalb
und fünfeinhalb.
Ich arbeite 60 %
als Oberstufenlehrerin.
Meine Freizeit beschränkt sich
auf sehr wenige Tage im Monat,
an denen ich
noch wirklich etwas tun kann.
Ich war vor 50 Jahren schon mal
auf der Haute Route und ...
... es hat mich immer interessiert,
wie es heute aussieht -
die ganze Umgebung.
Für mich ist das
die letzte Gelegenheit,
noch einmal
auf die Haute Route zu gehen.
Ich habe die Tourenski
quasi von meiner Mutter geerbt.
Dann waren diese Ski da,
und das hat schon auch
den Reiz ausgelöst.
Was hat sie dazu gebracht?
Wieso hat sie so gerne
Skitouren gemacht?
Ich will das nachfühlen.
Das ist das Besondere.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Was erwartet die Gruppe?
Die Haute Route ist eine Heraus-
forderung für alle, die sie wagen.
Bergführer David Fasel aus Verbier
führt seit Jahren regelmässig
Gäste über diese Route.
Der Start zur Tour war heute Morgen
in Argentière neben Chamonix.
Von dort ging es hoch
zur Argentièrehütte.
Morgen wird die Gruppe zur Cabane
du Trient in der Schweiz weitergehen,
dann über Verbier
hoch zur Cabane Mont Fort.
Von dort in die Cabane des Dix,
ins Bivouac de Bouquetins.
Die Ankunft
ist am sechsten Tag in Zermatt.
7'000 Höhenmeter, 80 km,
meistens auf 3'000 m Höhe
inmitten der Viertausender
warten auf das Team.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
* Lautlos *
Morgen. Bist du schon wach?
Mein Magen spinnt.
- Nein!
Ich hab kein Auge zugetan.
- Nicht im Ernst. Vom Abendessen?
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Der nächste Morgen beginnt
mit einer unangenehmen Überraschung.
Gut geschlafen?
- Nein, es hat mir den Magen ...
Es hat meinen Magen ...
War dir schlecht?
- Ja.
Richtig übel. Etwas war nicht gut.
Bist du auf dem WC gelandet?
- Ja, eben erbrechen.
Ich mache heute langsam.
David Fasel wird heute
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen müssen.
Jetzt, die Felle.
Haben alle ein Fell dabei?
Den Pickel?
- Ja.
Steigeisen?
Das ist so das Wichtigste.
Wir rutschen hier gerade runter.
Einfach langsam gehen und
etwas Distanz zwischen euch lassen!
Bruno, bis da unten,
wo wir dann die Felle montieren,
gehen wir zusammen.
Ich gehe voraus, du folgst.
Dann gehen wir einfach gemütlich.
Der Schnee ist pickelhart
nach einer eiskalten Nacht.
Und die erste Abfahrt
führt durch steiles Gelände.
Vor solchen Passagen
hatte der 72-jährige Paul Zeller
bereits im Vorfeld Respekt.
* Spannende Musik *
(Paul) Verdammt noch mal!
Paul, aufstehen! Aufstehen!
- Verdammt noch mal!
Nimm die Ski noch mal zurück!
Mach den Ski auch parallel!
So ist gut.
CEO Severin Moser muss eingreifen.
Er hilft, damit Paul nicht
in die steilen Felsen abrutscht.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Die nächste Schwierigkeit
wartet bereits:
der Aufstieg zum Col du Chardonnet.
Die kämpfen da oben ziemlich
mit den Harscheisen.
Planänderung: Steigeisen an und
die Ski auf den Rucksack schnallen.
Die wenigsten haben bisher
viel Erfahrung
mit dem Gehen auf Steigeisen.
Habe ich das richtig eingefädelt?
Ja.
Jetzt muss ich das so ...
Ich habe
zum ersten Mal Steigeisen an
und zum zweiten Mal
Ski auf dem Rücken.
Aber eine so lange Passage
habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Aufgebrochen ist die Gruppe
heute in der Argentièrehütte.
Jetzt sind sie
im ersten Aufstieg
auf den Col du Chardonnet.
Weiter geht es
über das Fenêtre de Saleina
zur Besteigung der Aiguille du Tour.
Ziel ist die Cabane du Trient
auf 3'170 m.
Über 10 km und 1'040 Höhenmeter
beinhaltet dieser Tag.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Dafür sind 5-7 Std.
reine Laufzeit geplant.
Es ist der erste Test.
Bergführer David muss herausfinden,
wie sicher die Gruppe unterwegs ist.
Haltet die Stöcke gut fest!
Es kam schon vor,
dass sie verloren gingen.
Das war gerade eine Stelle,
an der man nicht ausrutschen sollte.
Es würde nicht viel passieren,
aber so ein paar blaue Flecken
hätte man danach schon.
Aber dafür, dass Peter
zum ersten Mal mit Steigeisen geht,
geht das ganz gut.
(Yolanda) Wie geht's dir, Papi?
- Ja, so weit gut.
Es ist einfach etwas steil.
Direkt hinter dem 72-jährigen Paul
ist seine Tochter Yolanda.
Jeder sucht seinen eigenen Rhythmus
in knapp 3'000 m Höhe -
nicht nur Carmen und Peter,
sondern auch die ehemalige
Spitzensportlerin Dominique Gisin.
Bergführer Bruno Jelk folgt.
Langsam, geschwächt
von seiner Magenverstimmung.
Gleich etwas trinken!
Legt eure Sonnenbrillen
nicht zu weit weg.
Wir brauchen sie
vielleicht plötzlich.
Ich würde am liebsten
mit Steigeisen weitergehen.
Es gefällt mir nicht,
dass wir Felle aufziehen müssen.
Warum?
- Es gibt eine andere Sicherheit.
Es ist früher Morgen
und mit der Spitzkehre ...
Ich fühle mich so sicherer,
und es ist angenehmer,
wenn es gerade schon läuft.
Felle aufziehen
und Harscheisen montieren.
Dominique
greift Fränzi unter die Arme.
Das ist das Blöde
ohne Servicemann, was?
Ich habe ja einen.
Ich bin froh drum.
Die hatte ich noch nie dran.
Nächstes Mal
weiss ich es hoffentlich.
* Eindringliche Musik *
700 m Aufstieg.
Auch die ehemaligen Weltcup-
fahrerinnen sind technisch gefordert.
Schauen wir mal! Er hat mir einen
Tipp für diese Spitzkehre gegeben.
Er ist auch sportlich fit.
Aber wie macht man das jetzt?
Das ist ...
So.
- Aha, mehr so?
Ja, ja.
- Aber nicht zu viel, ja.
Ja, so ... Genau.
So geht's leichter.
Ja, wir machen noch ein paar.
Das lohnt sich.
Danke.
- Der kann natürlich ...
Der macht schon Sport,
sonst würde er das nicht schaffen.
Nah am Erbrechen.
Ausgerechnet Bruno Jelk
leidet heute am meisten.
Er ist es gewohnt,
als Bergführer vorauszugehen,
und kennt die Haute Route bestens.
(David) Steigeisen anziehen,
Felle wegnehmen
und die Ski
auf den Rucksack schnallen.
Bruno, dir geht's nicht gut, was?
Nein. Wenn das nicht besser wird,
hat es keinen Sinn.
Keine Chance?
Aber ... Wollen wir nicht
in der Hütte mal schauen?
Können wir machen, aber wenn's
nicht geht, hat das keinen Sinn.
Ich bin immer nah am Kotzen,
weisst du? - Aha, ja, ja.
Da bekommt man nicht richtig Luft.
- Ja.
Aber wir gehen jetzt noch ein
bisschen, und dann entscheiden wir.
Wenn's nicht geht, geht's nicht.
- Ja, ja.
Wir schauen mal.
Ich muss einfach langsamer gehen.
Ja. Gut, tipptopp.
Wie geht es mit Bruno weiter?
Die Gruppe ist gross.
Sie braucht zwei Bergführer,
um sicher durch die Woche zu kommen.
* Eindringliche,
majestätische Musik *
Nach 3 Std. ist
der Col du Chardonnet in Griffnähe -
das Tor zu den Walliser Alpen.
3'323 m sind erreicht.
Die Grenze
zwischen Frankreich und der Schweiz.
Dahinter: ein steiles Couloir.
Den Karabiner lösen!
Der zweite Teil ist nicht so steil.
Haltet euch am Fixseil fest
und geht runter.
David sichert die Passage
mit einem Seil.
Man darf einfach
nicht zu schnell runtergehen.
Yolanda macht den Anfang.
Am Anfang ist es ziemlich steil,
aber unten können sie
dem Fixseil allein folgen.
Seil frei!
Danke. Du kannst gemütlich losgehen.
- Ja, ist gut.
Für Yolanda
ist der Abstieg kein Problem,
denn sie ist SAC-Tourenleiterin.
Ich lasse dich langsam runter.
Als Nächstes
ist ihr Vater Paul an der Reihe.
(David) Gut.
Ja, schön breit stehen. Tipptopp.
Paul seilt sich
nicht zum ersten Mal ab.
(Paul) Nein, nein.
- Nein, nein.
Er hat schon einige Kilometer
abgeseilt.
Und der Papa?
- Ja, das geht gut.
Hier runter,
das ist für ihn nicht so schlimm.
Die blöde Abfahrt heute Morgen
war für ihn das Schlimmste.
Dieses Steinharte.
So.
Geht's gut?
- Ja, ja.
Oben wartet Peter.
Nervös, aber zuversichtlich.
Gut.
Du hast dich auch schon abgeseilt?
- Nein.
Das ist nicht nur für mich eine
Visitenkarte, sondern auch für dich.
Das stimmt. Hast du das Geschirr
richtig geschlossen? Gut.
Also, einfach schön aufrecht stehen
und breitbeinig rückwärts gehen.
Ich mache am Anfang schön langsam.
- Ja, gerne.
Ich gebe mir Mühe. Und die Richtung?
- Bravo, gut gemacht!
Das geht gut.
- Du kannst ruhig hochschauen.
Nicht auf die Füsse schauen!
(David) Gut! Gut, Peter!
(Yolanda) Super, Peter!
Ja, ich fahre schon ...
Ich fahre schon gerne Verschiedenes.
Aber es wäre ...
Es wäre sicher eine Herausforderung.
Es wäre nicht völlig alltäglich.
Aber deswegen sind wir ja hier.
Die Olympiasiegerin
bringt sich in Position.
Als Einzige wagt Dominique Gisin
die Abfahrt
im engen und steilen Couloir.
(David) Fahren!
* Spannende, heroische Musik *
Hier sind all die Steine.
Einen Sturz am Anfang der Tour
wäre verhängnisvoll -
aber Dominique
ist sich solche Passagen
vom Freeriden
in ihrer Heimat Engelberg gewohnt.
Yolanda nutzt die Pause
für eine SMS an ihre Kinder.
Ja, kurz schauen,
ob es den Kindern gut geht.
Ich schicke ihnen ein Küsschen.
Die Bilder gehen nicht raus,
aber sie bekommen zumindest
ein Küsschen von mir.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Wenn ich die Chance bekomme,
nehme ich mir diese Auszeit jetzt."
Meine Mutter hat gesagt:
"Mach's, wenn du die Chance hast!"
"Ist gut. Mach's!"
Es war dann schon immer wieder so:
"Ja, soll ich wirklich?"
"Darf ich das als Mutter?"
Aber ... ja.
Ich bin jetzt hier und es ist gut.
Und den Kindern
geht's sicher auch gut.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Die Gruppe
ist jetzt seit 5 Std. unterwegs.
Die Sonne brennt auf den Gletscher.
Es geht hinauf
zum nächsten Felsübergang,
zum Fenêtre de Saleina.
Das ist ein ziemliches Loch hier.
Hast du das gesehen?
Vorbei
an offenen Gletscherspalten.
Ein Fehltritt
kann fatale Folgen haben.
Geht's, Paul?
- Ja, geht schon.
Pass auf, dass du nicht abrutschst.
- Ja, warte!
Versuch, aufzustehen.
Geh ihm mal helfen.
Yolanda hilft ihrem Vater.
(David) Damit das gerade wird.
- Die Steighilfe muss draussen sein.
Dann geht's besser. So, jetzt.
- Vielleicht geht's besser.
Ich probier's mal,
sonst schnallen wir sie auf.
(Yolanda) Ist gut, wenn ich ...
- (David) Ja, das geht nicht.
Gut.
Zur Sicherheit
zieht die Gruppe Steigeisen an.
* Eindringliche, pulsierende Musik *
Es folgen
weitere 100 m steiler Aufstieg
bis zum Fenêtre de Saleina -
und es ist erst
der zweite Tag der Tour.
Vater und Tochter sind die Ersten.
(Yolanda) Super!
* Paul keucht. *
Perfekt.
Wie geht's Bruno?
- Tja ...
Es wird schon,
aber gerade mit der Hitze ...
Es schlaucht ihn,
aber es wird schon.
Schau, da kommt Peter!
Peter, steh auf!
Gut, ja. Es geht einfacher,
wenn du aufrecht bist.
Komm, noch drei Schritte! Schön.
Ah! Das war sehr anstrengend.
Alles gut?
- Alles gut, aber anstrengend.
Bruno Jelk - der Mann, der es
schon ein Leben lang gewohnt ist,
auf der ganzen Welt Leben zu retten -
hat im Aufstieg
sein Gepäck abgeben müssen.
Bruno, wie geht's dir?
- Ja, mühsam, nicht?
Ich glaube,
ich tausche mit dem Aspiranten.
Das bringt mehr.
Also, ich gehe noch auf den Berg da.
David plant derweil
eine zusätzliche Klettertour.
Bis auf den Gipfel?
- Ja, den mittleren.
Das geht auch wieder so hoch.
- Oben ist es Felsklettern.
Meinst du, ich schaff das?
- Ja.
2 Std. hin und zurück? Wir müssen
noch für die nächsten Tage ...
Ja, morgen ist schon noch ...
Ach, komm doch einfach mit!
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Nicht alle haben sich für den
zusätzlichen Gipfel entschieden.
Bruno fährt mit Paul und Peter
über den Gletscher
direkt zur Cabane du Trient.
Während die anderen weiter
zur Aiguille du Tour aufsteigen.
Inzwischen ist es Mittag.
Nach dem eiskalten Morgen
herrschen auf 3'000 m Höhe
jetzt Sommertemperaturen.
Die Trinkflaschen sind fast leer,
der Proviant gegessen.
Auch Olympiasiegerin Dominique Gisin
kämpft in der Hitze.
Auch das ist nicht wie im Lehrbuch.
Und die Kletterpartie
steht noch bevor.
Jetzt muss ich was trinken.
Ich habe solchen Durst.
Peter, Bruno und Paul
sind fast schon am Ziel.
Die Cabane du Trient
ist ein alter Steinbau,
die erste Hütte auf Schweizer Boden.
Übernachtet wird auf 3'170 m.
Bruno, geht's?
Nein, ich kann mich nicht erholen.
Ich kann nicht erbrechen, weisst du?
Hat sich das mit dem Laufen
nicht verbessert?
Nein. Ich muss mich abkämpfen, damit
ich einigermassen mithalten kann.
Als erfahrener Bergführer kennt Bruno
die Strapazen der Haute Route
und weiss: Wer nicht 100%ig fit ist,
kann die Tour nicht durchstehen.
Ich dachte:
"Ja, die Woche ist noch lang."
Darum ist für heute genug.
Paul?
- Für mich ...* Räuspern *
Für mich ist es einfach,
weil die Woche noch lang ist.
Diesen Gipfel muss ich
nicht unbedingt gehabt haben.
Ich muss meine Kräfte
für die ganze Woche schonen,
also einteilen.
Und morgen wird auch wieder happig.
Ich hatte ja zwei Hüftoperationen.
Da habe ich einen
ziemlichen Rückschlag erlitten.
Ich habe natürlich schon
Training eingebüsst,
also dort eine Einbusse erlebt.
Das merke ich auch.
Er spricht von Kräfte einteilen -
das merke ich auch.
Es ist auch mit 56 nicht mehr so,
wie es mal war, ganz klar.
Inzwischen ist David mit
seiner Gruppe kurz vor dem Gipfel.
Schön, wie im Sommer.
Alle sind mitgekommen, auch Carmen.
Durst. Ist es klug,
aus dieser Gosse zu trinken?
David,
darf ich aus dieser Pfütze trinken?
Nein, das mache ich nicht.
- (Fränzi) Trink einfach!
Also, ich trinke einfach.
- (David) Du kannst auch lecken.
Da unten ist noch ein Molch.
(Fränzi, lachend)
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Nein.
* Schlürfen *
Sie trinkt.
Ja.
Nach über 7 Std. ist
der erste Gipfel der Tour erreicht.
Gratuliere. Danke vielmals.
Gratuliere.
Gratuliere auch.
- Gratuliere.
Danke sehr und ganz gute Besserung.
Danke.
- Und sonst in Zermatt. Danke auch.
Schweren Herzens
hat Bruno entschieden,
mit dem Heli, der für Kamerateams
und Transport zuständig ist,
ins Tal zu fliegen.
Er hofft,
dass er sich in Zermatt erholen kann,
um vielleicht später
noch einmal zurückzukommen.
Währenddessen geniesst Davids Gruppe
die erste lange Abfahrt des Tages.
Juhui, endlich!
* Majestätische,
eindringliche Musik *
Nach über 8 Std.
werden die Gipfelstürmer
in der Cabane du Trient erwartet.
Zeig mal eine Dose!
- Das macht sie fertig.
Nein, im Gegenteil.
Wollt ihr ein Bier haben?
- Was?
Ein Bier?
- Hauptsache, was zu trinken.
Das würde ich auch meinen.
- Es gibt Cola.
Ihr könnt die Ski hier ausziehen.
Ihr müsst sie nachher runtertragen.
Ihr seid Schätze.
- Hier.
Ah, danke.
- Super.
Danke vielmals.
- Hey, bravo.
Danke.
- Zum Wohl! Bravo!
Danke vielmals.
- Bravo.
Angekommen. Zum Wohl!
Ja, es ist einfach so heiss.
Wirklich abartig.
Ich bin nicht
für diese Wärme gemacht.
(Fränzi) Um morgens
für 5 Min. nicht frieren zu müssen,
war mir jetzt 6 Std. zu heiss.
So lernt man.
Und Ralph.
Ralph ist ein Kamel. Der braucht ...
Der kann auch drei Tage
ohne Getränke sein.
Ralph Weber, der Bergführer,
der für das Filmteam zuständig ist,
hat sich Carmen angenommen.
(Peter) Es war sicher heiss.
- Ja.- Das wundert mich nicht.
Du, vielen Dank.
- Gerne.
Danke dir.
- Alles Gute! Du hast es geschafft.
Jetzt habe ich es dir über
den Rücken gekippt. Dreh dich um!
Nicht halb so wild.
- Pardon!
Hey, du hast es geschafft.
Gratuliere.- Danke.
Ich war zwei-, dreimal so ...
Vom Psychischen her hatte ich
während des Aufstiegs wirklich Mühe.
Ich habe Mühe,
wenn ich an andere angeseilt bin.
Das ist ein wenig wie Platzangst -
nicht weg oder ausweichen können.
Und dann ging es
wirklich ziemlich steil abwärts.
Die Höhe ist auch nicht mein Ding.
Beim Fliegen
hat mir das sehr gefallen,
und auf Bahnen und so
ist es auch so,
aber hier hatte ich wirklich
etwas Mühe damit.
Santé!
- Gesundheit!
Auch CEO Severin Moser
geniesst die Pause.
Hast du bis jetzt mal
deine E-Mails gecheckt?
Nein, habe ich noch nicht.
- Und jetzt?
Jetzt ... schaue ich mal.
Aber ich habe vorhin gesehen,
dass ich keinen Empfang habe.
Für die E-Mails müsste ich
auf diesen Hügel steigen.
Ich habe mich noch nicht
dazu durchringen können.
(Peter) Noch nicht.
- Vielleicht gehe ich noch.
Ich habe aber geschaut,
und ich habe 23 WhatsApps.
Die meisten sind privat,
aber einige sind auch geschäftlich.
Severin Moser
ist ehemaliger Zehnkämpfer
und trainiert noch heute täglich.
Als CEO bei der Allianz Schweiz
führt er 3'500 Mitarbeiter
und hat sich vorgenommen, in dieser
Woche keine Mails zu beantworten.
Es sind 38 E-Mails reingekommen.
- In zwei Tagen?
Ja. Das ist nicht so schlimm, oder?
Wenn ich ehrlich bin,
habe ich ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn ich daran denke,
dass die anderen jetzt
in einem Sitzungszimmer sind
und irgendwo da unten im Dunst
eine Sitzung abhalten,
während wir so tolles Wetter
und so ein Panorama haben.
Man darf sich selbst
nicht zu wichtig nehmen.
Man ist ja ein Rädchen
im ganzen Räderwerk.
Natürlich hat man eine exponierte
und wahrscheinlich
wichtige Funktion,
aber jeder ist letztlich ersetzbar.
Wenn man sich
nicht allzu wichtig nimmt,
kann man auch mal
so eine Woche überstehen.
Zu ersetzen ist im Team
Bergführer Bruno Jelk.
Jetzt haben wir eben das Problem,
dass Bruno uns verlassen musste -
wegen des Magens und ...
Aber so ist es jetzt einfach.
Wir ziehen trotzdem weiter.
Wir haben das besprochen und gesagt,
dass wir ja noch eine erfahrene
Berggängerin dabei haben.
Wenn wir
zwei Seilschaften machen müssen,
ist Yolanda Seilführerin
der zweiten Seilschaft.
Ist das gut für dich?
- Das ist gut für mich.
Ist das gut für euch?
- (Alle) Ja.
Aber morgen versuchen wir,
ein wenig Ski zu fahren,
nicht nur zu traversieren.
- Yes!
Ist das gut? Passt das?
- Super, ja, das passt.
David will
mit SAC-Tourenleiterin Yolanda
vorerst allein weitermachen
und hofft,
dass Bruno wieder fit wird.
* Klagender Frauengesang *
Das ist keine Philosophie.
Am nächsten Morgen
ist um 4.30 Uhr Tagwache.
Fränzi ist eher ein Morgenmensch.
- Man sieht nichts.
Jeden Tag übernachtet die Gruppe
gemeinsam in einer anderen Hütte.
Der Ablauf des Morgens
folgt einem Ritual.
Zuerst wird der Rucksack gepackt.
Das Gepäck für eine Woche
tragen alle selbst -
ein Rucksack wiegt
mit Steigeisen und Pickel 10 kg.
Bevor es losgeht, werden
die Lawinensuchgeräte kontrolliert.
* Piepen *
Das Wetter ist bisher stabil,
und auch die Prognosen sehen gut aus.
Die kalten Morgenstunden
sind wichtig und geben Sicherheit.
Die Gruppe muss gegen 14 Uhr
in der nächsten Hütte sein,
da es am Nachmittag
wieder heiss werden soll
und damit die Gefahr
von Nassschneelawinen steigt.
* Mystischer Frauengesang *
Jeden Tag, immer weiter,
nie einen Tag Ruhe
in über 3'000 m Höhe -
das ist eine der Herausforderungen
der Haute Route.
Nicht schön, oh.
Aber da muss man durch.
Es ist schon etwas steil.
David.
- Ja?
Sollen wir die Steigeisen anziehen?
- Nein, für die paar ...
Es sind nur 20 m, dann ist gut.
Die Gruppe wird bereits
am frühen Morgen
von einem Steilstück
voll vereister Spuren überrascht.
Geht's?
- Nein, nicht so gut.
Wie?
- Nicht so gut.
Komm mal hier runter.
Ein harter Einstieg in den Tag.
Nicht nur für Paul, der schon gestern
an einer ähnlichen Stelle stürzte.
Ist nicht so schlimm, oder?
Wenn man von Anfang an anseilt,
ist es gut.
Ich hab langsam genug.
Nein, ja, also mit diesen Schuhen
habe ich das Gefühl ...
... über diesen Schnee.
Was ist, wenn das Seil reisst?
Wenn es sein müsste,
würde ich es überleben.
Aber Spass macht das nicht.
- Eben genau.
Fränzi Aufdenblatten befürchtet,
dass sich die Tourenbindung
durch einen Schlag öffnen könnte.
Sie wählt das sichere Seil.
Wieder ist es Dominique Gisin,
die als Einzige die Abfahrt wagt.
Ja, ja.
Es ist schon verdammt hart.
- Ja, ja.
So richtig hart.
Du bist es gewohnt,
auf so hartem Zeug zu fahren.
Aber nicht
mit solchen Hindernissen dazwischen.
Ich sagte, der Pistenfahrer
habe heute Nacht versagt.
Es war etwas unheimlich,
es ist steil.
Es ist der Moment,
in dem man lernt, mutig zu sein.
Aber jetzt ist es schön.
Jetzt wird es etwas weicher.
Bis wir den anderen Hang
runterfahren können, ist es sulzig.
Die dritte Etappe
führt von der Cabane du Trient
auf den Col de la Grande Lui.
Eine lange Abfahrt
bis ins Tal nach La Fouly.
Dann mit Bus nach Verbier
und mit der Bahn
wieder hoch zur Cabane Mont Fort.
600 m Aufstieg und 1'700 m Abfahrt
sind heute zu überwinden.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Es ist das Erlebnis der Skitour,
aber auch die Ruhe, die Einsamkeit,
die alle auf der Haute Route
gesucht haben.
Für kurze Zeit aus den Pflichten
des Alltags ausbrechen.
Sich Zeit dafür nehmen,
wovon man geträumt hat.
Und dem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzufügen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Wieder sind es lange Aufstiege
mit Fell und Ski.
Über weite Gletscher
und steile Couloirs,
die nur mit Steigeisen
zu bewältigen sind.
* Angestrengtes Atmen *
(David) Okay, tipptopp!
Die Felle wegnehmen. Ähm ...
Steigeisen anziehen,
Ski auf den Rucksack binden.
Die Stöcke ebenfalls
auf den Rucksack, und Pickel nehmen.
Yolanda, Severin und Fränzi
machen eine Seilschaft,
und der Rest kommt mit mir.
Yolanda,
die heute für Bruno einspringt,
nimmt die erfahrenen Berggänger
ans Seil.
Ja. Ja, coole Sache.
Schön da hoch.
Tolle Leute am Seil.
Es läuft was.
Die Laune? Ja, die ist besser,
als noch vor 30 Min.
Ich habe es ohne Fluchen geschafft.
Aber ich merke es schon.
Gut, ich bin auch eine Susi,
ich jammere gerne, muss ich sagen.
Da bin ich ehrlich.
* Lachen *
Fränzi lacht.
Fränzi kann immer dumm schwatzen,
das ist ihr Vorteil.
Sie bringt sogar noch was raus,
wenn sie am Limit ist.
Dein Jammern
ist nachher das Grinsen.
* Windrauschen *
Vor ihnen
liegt das 200 m steile Couloir
über den Col de la Grande Lui,
die heutige Schlüsselstelle.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Gut, es geht.
(David) Das ist der ...
Vorsicht, warten!
Der Bergschrund.
Der Hang ist steil,
furchteinflössend für jene,
die es nicht gewohnt sind,
mit Steigeisen zu gehen.
(David) Gut, du kannst kommen.
Nicht am Seil festhalten.
Heute ist David
als Bergführer besonders gefragt.
Peter, nicht am Seil festhalten!
Er hat die weniger erfahrenen
Berggänger am Seil.
Yolanda folgt in sicherem Abstand
mit Fränzi und Severin.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(David) Können wir weiter?
Warte,
bis der Reissverschluss zu ist!
Yolanda, hier kannst du gut sichern.
- Okay.
Vorsicht, Stein!
(David) Gut, ja.
Immer schön weitergehen!
Stein!
Super, Peter, komm!
Es ist nicht mehr weit.
Vorsicht, das Seil unten,
du stehst drauf.
(Peter) Gut.
Das geht gut.
Ist der brüchige Fels kein Problem?
- Wie?
Mit dem brüchigen Fels.
- Nein.
Warte bitte, bis ich es sage!
Gut, du kannst kommen.
Pass auf,
dass du nicht aufs Seil ...
Sie macht das sehr ruhig.
Das gibt mir auch Ruhe.
Du kannst gehen,
sobald das Seil gestreckt ist.
Ich finde es schon cool, wenn es
in einem Schwierigkeitsgrad ist,
in dem ich mich wohlfühle.
Und wenn die Kapazität da ist,
ich für die anderen schauen kann.
Fränzi, ich komme auch.
Wie bitte?
- Ich komme auch.
Ruhig und gelassen
führte Yolanda ihre Seilschaft
durch die steile Flanke.
Wie lange brauchten wir?
- 20 oder 30 Min.
Weg mit den Steigeisen.
Jetzt folgt, worauf sich die Skirenn-
fahrerinnen am meisten gefreut haben:
eine lange Abfahrt.
Von 3'500 m bis ins Tal auf 1'600 m.
Über die weiten Flächen
des Gletschers.
Bergführer David Fasel
fährt mit Dominique,
Fränzi und Severin vorne weg.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Bergführer Ralph Weber folgt
mit Yolanda und der zweiten Gruppe.
Die schneebedeckte Fläche
des Gletschers ist tückisch.
Immer wieder tauchen unvermittelt
riesige Spalten auf,
die für die Gruppe
schwer ersichtlich sind.
Huch, ja!
Mega.
- So sieht's schön aus.
Jetzt kannst du hier hinten schauen.
Bei solchen Sachen
geht man jeweils zu Fuss.
Ja, ja.
(Dominique) Ja, hier
ist es schwieriger geworden.
(Fränzi) Zeitweise
hebt es einen fast aus den Schuhen.
Mich hob es mal so, dass mir
der Rucksack an den Kopf knallte.
Gut, trage ich einen Helm.
* Dominique lacht. *
(Dominique) Der Saharastaub.
- (Fränzi) Ja, nicht wahr?
1 Std.
hat die Abfahrt von über 3'000 m
bis ins Tal nach La Fouly gedauert.
(David) Du hast mich
im Skifahren fertiggemacht.
Yolanda, vielen Dank.
- Merci, Yolanda, gut geführt.
Wir sind jetzt in der Hälfte.
In der Hälfte der Haute Route.
- Ja.
Noch nicht ganz, aber ...
(Fränzi) Ist morgen
der schlimmste Tag?- Nein.
Übermorgen?
- Nein.
Es gibt keinen.
Aber was denkt ihr bisher?
Gefällt es euch?
Oder würdet ihr am liebsten heute
abbrechen und nach Hause gehen?
Zieht ihr es durch bis nach Zermatt?
- Klar ziehen wir es durch.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Ist es ein Müssen
oder macht es euch Spass?
Es macht viel Spass.
Wir haben goldige Bedingungen.
Habt ihr es euch so vorgestellt?
Oder habt ihr es euch anders,
weniger streng vorgestellt?
Oder strenger?
Ich dachte, die Passagen
mit Abseilen und so seien weniger.
Hast du das gar nicht erwartet?
Ähm ...
- Nicht so extrem steil.
Nicht so extrem steil, nein.
- Mir geht es gleich.
Es ging dann gut, es war okay.
Oder z.B.
mit den Steigeisen hoch ...
Wie heute Morgen?
- Mit den Ski auf dem Rücken.
Das stellte ich mir schon vor,
aber es war doch relativ steil.
Also, hätten wir einmal
einen Schritt nach hinten gemacht,
wären wir ...
hättest du uns gehalten.
* Lachen *
Genau.
- Normalerweise.
Normalerweise.
(Fränzi)
Es gibt etwas Abwechslung, oder?
Wenn man nur mit den Fellen
gehen, gehen, gehen würde,
wäre es nicht ...
Paul, hast du es dir so vorgestellt?
Du hast es
schon vor 50 Jahren gemacht.
Ich kannte das schon.
Ich kannte es vom Bergsteigen.
- Ja, ja.
Einzig die Abfahrt gestern,
die war etwas hart.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr daran.
- Frühmorgens.
Ach so.
Aber heute ging's gut?
- Heute ging's gut.
Als wir das Seil ...
Am Anfang hast du schon etwas ...
Ja, als es runterging.
- Aber mit dem Seil war's gut.
Ja, mit dem Seil schon.
Ja, aber du bist in der Hüfte
halt nicht mehr 35 Jahre alt.
Gut, das ist halt einfach so.
Dann gehen wir weiter, oder?
- (Peter) Bist du zufrieden mit uns?
Ja, ich gehe gerne
mit euch nach Zermatt.
Ja, gib ihnen einen Kuss von mir!
Ja. Ja, ist gut.
Ja, der ist sowieso ... ja.
Gut, also ...
Tschüss, danke. Tschau.
Ja, ist gut. Tschau.
Sie sind am Spielen,
haben keine Zeit für die Mama.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Yolanda ist seit drei Jahren
alleinerziehende Mutter zweier Buben
und war in all der Zeit
noch nie länger von ihnen getrennt.
Weiter geht die Tour
per Bus nach Verbier,
dann mit der Bahn
ins Skigebiet von Mont-Fort
zur Mont-Fort-Hütte auf 2'457 m.
* Fröhliche Akkordeonklänge *
Die Hütte steht mitten im Skigebiet
und ist
mit allem Komfort ausgestattet.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Hallo? Familie?
Ah, hier sind wir.
Wir sind schon zu viert,
weil ihr Vater noch kommt.
Ah.
- Also nicht, dass ...
Dann ... Wo ist noch eines? Links?
Hallo?
Du stehst mir im Weg.
- Aber nur ein wenig, oder?
Ja. Gut.
Ich glaube, du bist hier.
Sie haben keinen Platz für mich,
weil Yolandas Papi dort ist.
Ihr müsst leider
mit mir Vorlieb nehmen.
Was heisst hier leider?
- Ich quassel wieder.
Du darfst natürlich zu den Ladys.
- Aha.
Nach drei Tagen eine erste Dusche.
Huch!
* Stimmengewirr *
Wollt ihr schon was trinken?
Soll ich eine Flasche Weisswein ...
- Das wäre ... Nicht Weisswein.
Ich muss zuerst Wasser haben.
- Kriegst du.
Beides.
- Beides. Und Weisswein.
Zum Wohl. Es war
ein megaschöner Tag. Zum Wohl.
Danke. Viva.
- Zum Wohl.
Eine schöne Idee.
Zeit, zu entspannen.
Oder wie in Dominique Gisins
und Fränzi Aufdenblattens Fall:
auf ihre Beziehung als Weltcup-
fahrerinnen und Konkurrentinnen
zurückzublicken.
Es kommt drauf an.
Wir standen uns nie extrem nahe.
Genau. Und jetzt vielleicht ...
Es ist wie im normalen Leben.
Ich glaube, mit einigen
entsteht eine echte Freundschaft
und mit anderen kommt man gut aus,
aber es ist nicht so, dass wir
gemeinsam Ferien gemacht hätten.
Nein.
- Es ist wie im Job.
Einigen steht man näher,
anderen weniger.
Ja, es ist auch ein Job.
- Es ist ja eigentlich unser Job.
Aber generell ist es speziell,
dass man danach wenig Kontakt hat
zu den Leuten,
mit denen man gefahren ist.
Denn davor spielte sich das Leben
irgendwie am selben Ort ab,
doch jetzt ist man verstreut.
Habt ihr jetzt andere Seiten
voneinander kennengelernt?
Ihr kanntet euch ja schon gut.
Ja, das ...
- Es ist schwierig, noch etwas ...
Oder könnt ihr etwas relativieren?
Es ist einfach gechillter.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob es ist,
weil wir jetzt älter sind.
Ja.
Prinzipiell
ist der Konkurrenzdruck mal weg.
Genau.
- Der ist weg.
Auch wenn ...
Als sie Olympiasiegerin wurde,
konnte ich ja nicht mal
das Rennen fahren.
Es war einer der tougheren Momente.
Aber ich musste sagen:
"Die Leistung war einfach geil."
Sie konnte an diesem Tag
ihre Stärke voll ausspielen.
Dann musst du einfach sagen,
dass du den Hut ziehst.
Es hilft dir dann selbst auch,
damit umzugehen,
wenn du es dem anderen gönnst.
Es ist etwas, was ich gelernt habe:
Du tust dir keinen Gefallen,
wenn du anderen etwas nicht gönnst.
Wenn Fränzi das jetzt sagt, bedeutet
mir das natürlich sehr viel.
Denn sie weiss ganz genau,
welche Leistung das war.
Das ist eine grosse Lebensschule,
dass man damit umzugehen lernt.
* Gemächliche Akkordeonklänge *
Un peu du vin rou... blanc.
Die Gruppe wächst durch
die Herausforderungen der Haute Route
immer mehr zu einem Team zusammen.
Danke für die schöne Tour!
Nur einer fehlt:
Bergführer Bruno Jelk.
Ich habe mit Bruno telefoniert:
Ihm geht's nicht gut.
Der verbrachte den Tag auf dem Klo.
Wir dachten,
wir könnten ihn noch einfliegen.
Heute ging es ja tipptopp.
Wir haben aber dennoch entschieden -
weil wir
eine relativ grosse Gruppe sind
und unterschiedliche Niveaus
haben ...
Damit wir die Gruppe mal teilen und
auch mal einen Gipfel machen können,
brauchen wir doch noch jemanden,
der mir ein wenig hilft.
Es liegt auf der Hand: Ralph.
* Lachen, Applaus *
Morgen folgt die längste Tour.
Aber wir haben ja gerade
ein Fondue gegessen.
Um 4 Uhr aufstehen, um 5 Uhr los.
Die Tour beginnt
auf der Cabane Mont Fort.
Ein erster Aufstieg
auf den Col de la Chaux.
Es folgt die Rosablanche
auf über 3'000 m.
Und danach
eine lange Laufpassage am Lac des Dix
bis zur Cabane des Dix.
Mit 9 Std., 17 km
und 1'800 m Aufstieg
ist es die längste Etappe
der Haute Route.
Hier ist der mühsame Teil mit
den Fellen. Hier müssen wir beissen.
Es wird warm sein.
Dann geht es so flach nach hinten -
lange, lange, lange, lange ...
Wie viele Kilometer?
- Dem See entlang.
Ja, am See entlang bis zur Hütte.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Tagwache ist um 4 Uhr.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die erste Etappe startet auf
der vereisten Piste des Skigebietes.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Licht aus! Ich schlafe noch.
Die Wettervorhersage
ist immer noch gut.
Doch in den nächsten Tagen kündigt
sich eine Schlechtwetterfront an.
Im Tal sammelt sich
die Feuchtigkeit in den Wolken.
Erste Blessuren
machen sich bemerkbar.
Blasen.
Aber wir reden nicht darüber.
Wir sind jetzt wohl
nicht mal 1 Std. gelaufen, 45 Min.
Schon über Blasen zu reden,
wenn es 9 Std. dauert?
Das nimmt ein böses Ende.
Es ist der vierte Tag
auf der Haute Route.
Über 24 Std.
mit Tourenski und Steigeisen
hat die Gruppe bereits in den Beinen.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Jeder kämpft für sich und versucht,
seinen eigenen Rhythmus zu finden.
Denn heute ist nicht nur der längste,
sondern auch
einer der härtesten Tage -
körperlich und mental.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Es dauert noch lange.
- Ja, ja.
Lieber laufen, wenn es noch nicht so
warm ist.-Schon gut.
Laufen, wenn es nicht so warm ist,
und reden, wenn es warm ist.
David drückt schon frühmorgens
aufs Tempo.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Gegen Mittag wird es wieder heiss.
Hinter der Bergkette
ist der Lac des Dix,
der direkt in der Lawinenzone liegt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Jacken ausziehen!
(Dominique) Geht's hier weiter?
Oder weiter aufwärts?
Äh, ja ... äh ...
Aber jetzt ist es zunächst flach.
Der Spitz hier vorn
ist die Rosablanche.
Um vor Lawinen in der Fläche
des Lac des Dix sicher zu sein,
will David den Gipfel der Rosablanche
in 2 Std. erreicht haben.
Ich schicke ein paar Fotos.
Igitt, alles nass!
Das ist schon etwas eklig.
Warum hast du
die Mütze nicht ausgezogen?
Ich wäre genauso nass geworden.
Man muss immer noch
etwas Potenzial haben.
Es braucht die Möglichkeit,
noch etwas zu verbessern.
Wie beim Fahrrad:
nie den leichtesten Gang rein.
Einen braucht man noch als Reserve.
Reserven, die beim frühen Start
nicht alle zur Verfügung hatten.
Es geht etwas besser
und ich habe wohl auch rausgefunden,
woran es liegt.
Es ist mehr der Kopf,
es sind nicht die Beine.
Beim Hochgehen
taucht plötzlich die Frage auf:
"Was mache ich eigentlich?"
Die Frage nach dem Sinn.
Dann sind da viele
durchtrainierte Leute, Sportler,
die nebenher einfach reden können.
Ich denke: "Ich möchte
mitreden können, kann aber nicht."
Dazu fehlt mir die Puste.
Dann dreht es im Kopf: "Wer bin ich?
Was mache ich überhaupt hier?"
"Gehöre ich in diese Gruppe
oder nicht?"
"Warum schaffe ich es nicht,
mitzureden?"
Dann beginnt es zu rotieren,
das kennen wohl viele andere auch.
Dann muss ich das bewusst
wieder ausschalten und sagen:
"Es ist ein Paradies.
Schaut euch um! Es ist so schön."
Dann geht es wieder. Doch dann
kommen diese Stimmen wieder.
Dann wird man sie wieder los.
So in diesem Modus bin ich jetzt.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Laufen. Nur laufen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge
mit sphärischem Jodel *
Alleine mit sich,
der Natur und seinen Gedanken.
Stundenlang im gleichen Trott.
Keine Ablenkung. Nichts.
So Bewegungen, damit der Ellbogen
z.B. etwas mehr Luft bekommt -
so leichte Genusssachen.
Wie Abwechseln.
Der Takt.
Dass ich dem vor mir nicht auflaufe
und schaue, dass ich schön schiebe.
So immer ein wenig im Kreis.
Das geht gut.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
am dritten, vierten Tag
geht es immer besser mit der Höhe.
Man ist akklimatisiert
und hat das Gefühl fürs Material.
Es geht besser als am Anfang.
Ich sage, ich gehe mit grossen
Schritten meinem Zuhause entgegen.
Ob nun in der Traverse oder anders.
Aber es rückt schon näher.
Das ist cool. Ich freue mich.
Immer näher kommen sie der
Rosablanche und ihrem Ziel Zermatt.
Jetzt sind wir
aber nähergekommen, David.
Ja, ja.
- Es kommt immer näher.
Jetzt kommt es näher.
Jetzt gefällt es mir
besser als gestern.
Weit in der Ferne: das Matterhorn.
Von hier aus sieht man gut
die Dent Blanche, wie sie raucht.
Ja, genau.
Und da ist das Matterhorn.
Nicht Dent Blanche, Dent d'Hérens.
(Fränzi)
Das sieht aus wie ein Vulkan.
Ja, nicht wahr?
Carmen, hast du gesehen? Das ist
der einzige Vulkan in der Schweiz.
Der, der dort raucht.
- Ist kein AKW dahinter?
Nein, nein.
Könnte die Dent Blanche
nicht rechts sein?
Nein, Dent d'Hérens.
Wenn ich nach oben schaue ...
... brauche ich das Gelernte.
Aber ich schaffe das, das ist gut.
Gute Leute, guter Bergführer,
gute Motivatoren.
Es wird klappen.
Noch liegen aber
über zwei Tage vor ihnen,
bevor sie das Matterhorn erreichen.
Der Weg dahin führt
über die Besteigung der Rosablanche.
Weit unten im Tal, im Nebel,
liegt der Lac des Dix.
(Fränzi) Mein Pickel
ist einfach zu kurz.
David klettert wieder voran.
Ralph folgt mit der zweiten Gruppe.
(Ralph) Wenn man links hochschaut,
sieht man, wo wir runterfahren.
Der Hang nebenan.
- Ich schaue nicht hin.
(Carmen) Ralph, du hast zwei
mit leichter Höhenangst am Seil.
Die sind desinteressiert.
Wir kommen in den Nebel.
- (Ralph) Ja.
Sollen wir weitergehen?
- Langsam, ja.
Okay, ich gehe etwas langsamer.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Schon fast oben.
Gemeinsam erreichen alle
die Rosablanche.
Bravo. Gut gemacht.
Tipptopp gelaufen.
- Cool.
Fränzi, bravo.
- Merci.
Du warst super.
- Danke dir. Super.
Auch mit dabei der 72-jährige Paul.
Bist du stolz auf Papa?
- Ja, sicher.
Er zeigt eine super Leistung.
Genial.
Schön, jawohl.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Ein kurzes Geniessen.
Und weiter geht es hinunter
entlang der Fläche des Lac des Dix.
Die Gruppe
ist inzwischen seit 6 Std. unterwegs.
Der Nebel hat sich aufgelöst,
die Mittagshitze drückt.
Severin zieht mit Dominique Gisin
vorne weg.
Gefolgt von Peter.
Es ist heiss.
Und ich habe schon
einen langen Tag in den Knochen,
aber es geht.
Wenn man einen umgekehrten Stock
einfach so
in den Nassschnee stecken kann,
dann ist man schon zu spät dran.
Aber jetzt sind wir
hier auf der Fläche,
da spielt es nicht so eine Rolle.
Bei einer Hangfahrt hingegen
müssten wir das beachten.
Jetzt gehen wir
über dieses Flachstück,
das uns zum Nordhang führt,
wo das nicht so ein Problem ist.
Und oben ist es wieder flach
bis zur Hütte.
Aber wir müssen etwas Gas geben.
Etwas später - und wir dürften
nicht mehr dort entlang fahren.
Ja, es war ein harter Winter.
Ich habe gehört, dass es
letztes Jahr in den Schweizer Alpen,
ich will jetzt nichts behaupten,
fast 30 Tote gegeben habe.
Aber teils haben sich die Leute
auch fahrlässig verhalten.
Die Natur, das Wetter, sie können
über Leben und Tod entscheiden,
wie sich auch auf der Haute Route
einige Tage später zeigen wird.
Die Gruppe
hat sich inzwischen getrennt.
David wählt mit Severin, Fränzi,
Dominique, Yolanda und Peter
die Strecke hoch über dem Stausee,
hinweg über Nassschneelawinen.
Weisst du, ob dieser Dreck
den Skifellen schadet?
(Yolanda) Nein,
nicht wenn der Dreck trocken ist.
Sonst musst du die Felle
nachher eben ein bisschen putzen.
Paul und Carmen sind mit Ralph Weber
weiter unten am Lac des Dix
unterwegs.
Carmen bereiten die Blasen
an den Füssen immer mehr Schmerzen
und noch liegen
600 m Aufstieg vor ihnen.
Die anderen Mädels tun das auch.
Die anderen Mädchen sind mir egal.
Es wird jetzt einfach etwas warm.
Aber ich denke,
das schaffen wir jetzt schon noch,
diese 600 Höhenmeter.
Ich muss
die langen Unterhosen ausziehen,
weil ich mit den langen Unterhosen
noch schlafen will.
Was hat das mit dem Schlafen zu tun?
Weil sie dann schmutzig würden.
Das ist doch egal,
das ist doch bloss Staub
und gar kein richtiger Schmutz.
Mir ist es egal,
aber es geht um die Hütte dort.
Bist du das erste Mal
auf einer Hüttentour?
Ich bin eine saubere,
anständig erzogene Toggenburgerin,
die keinen Schmutz
in fremde Häuser bringt.
Tun das Toggenburger nicht?
Toggenburger
sind also übrigens anständig.
Was soll ich jetzt tun?
Es sieht schlimm aus.
Komm jetzt!
Deine Füsse stinken etwas.
Was? Meine Füsse stinken?
So ein Quatsch!
Sicher schon!
- Nur ein wenig.
Mach jetzt vorwärts mit deinem Fuss.
Aber so stark
stinken sie doch nicht?
Ich dachte, saubere
Toggenburgerinnen stinken nicht?
Nicht, wenn wir in das Haus
anderer Leute gehen.
Ist das wirklich so bei euch?
Vielleicht hilft etwas Fusssalbe.
Auch die schnellere Gruppe
leidet unter der Frühlingshitze.
Das Bild sagt genug.
Es wäre gelogen, zu sagen,
ich sei fit wie ein Turnschuh.
250.
Wie viel?
- 2'828.
Mach bitte keine Witze!
Nein, nein,
es sind nicht einmal 200 Höhenmeter.
Gut.
Das ist nicht gelogen.
Und schlafen werden wir heute
wie Babys,
wenn die Hütte nur auf 2'800 m ist.
Wahrscheinlich wird uns morgen
der linke Oberschenkel schmerzen.
David, wo geht es bei diesem Felsen
lang?- Rechts um die Ecke.
Gut. Und dann sieht man die Hütte?
- Ja.
Super.
Super! Sind wir bereit?
Sind wir bereit, können wir gehen?
Sind deine Füsse wieder gut?
Schmerzen deine Füsse beim Laufen?
Nein. Es ist super.
Ich spüre keinen Schmerz, nein.
So ist es richtig toll.
Auch die Oberschenkel
sind kein Thema mehr, nein.
Ralph steckt mit seiner Gruppe
immer noch unten am Stausee fest.
Gerade drüber und bremsen.
Oh, oh, Achtung!
Doch plötzlich ist
die Schneedecke voller Eisschollen
und Risse,
die schwer sichtbar sind.
Paul bleibt in einer Spalte stecken.
Hier geradeaus?
Oder oben herum?
Ja, hier hat es auch eine Spalte.
- Also direkt zu dir?
Scheisse!
Dort hat es eine weitere Spalte.
Ralph versucht,
Carmen und Paul sicher
durch die Spaltenzone zu lotsen.
Es war wie mit Kindern:
Alle 5 m fällt jemand um,
dann muss man ihm
wieder auf die Füsse helfen.
Das war die schlechteste Variante,
die wir laufen konnten.
Ach, das ist doch egal.
Ich dachte, das sei eine Abkürzung,
aber es war nun eher etwas länger.
Die anderen sind schon dort oben.
Die anderen sind dort oben, genau.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Kurz vor dem Ziel und doch noch weit.
So, die Ziellinie: flamme rouge.
Und auch Peter ist dabei,
er, der am Morgen
alles infrage gestellt hatte.
Ah, jetzt kann ich
den Rundblick geniessen.
Cool! Das ist zu schaffen.
Selbst Severin kämpft.
Eine Hütte, zu der wir
mit den Ski fahren könnten,
das wäre doch eine gute Idee.
Nach über 9 Std.
kräftezehrender Tour
erreicht die erste Gruppe
die Cabane des Dix.
Die armen Felle und Ski!
Bravo!
Gratuliere.
Wir sind alles harte Krieger.
Bravo!
Ich bin ziemlich am Anschlag.
Erschöpft.
Es war ein langer Weg.
Und es war heiss. Heiss.
Du warst
mit der schnellen Gruppe unterwegs.
Aber am Schluss.
Also, es gibt definitiv eine Formel,
bei der meine Leistungsfähigkeit
mit der Aussentemperatur korreliert.
Man könnte auch noch
den Windeinfluss dazurechnen,
der mich hier hoch
in diese Hütte gerettet hat.
Und die Nähe zu Schnee
hilft auch immer.
Gleiten?
- Ja.
Severin schulde ich vier Biere,
für jedes Mal,
als Wind aufkam beim Hochlaufen.
Und ... Nein, sonst war es ...
Es dauerte länger als gedacht.
Wer ist das dort? Ist das Paul?
- Ja, das dürfte mein Vater sein.
Mein Vater.
Er macht das sackstark,
in diesem Alter
noch so unterwegs zu sein.
Ja, etwas Augenpipi.
So?
Wir sind alle diese Rampe hoch.
Willst du das auch noch tun?
Gemeinsam noch einmal auf der
Haute Route Ð ein Traum für beide.
Zum Wohl.
- Ich bin froh um diese Pause.
Wenn ich bedenke,
dass mir 30-Jährige folgen,
bin ich voll zufrieden.
- Gratuliere.- Merci.
Nein, das war eine nahrhafte Sache.
Aber davon erholt man sich wieder.
* Jubel *
Hoppla!
- Oh, Entschuldigung.
Bravo, Paul. Was für ein Moment.
Du bist unglaublich.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Schön, bravo. Hat es geklappt?
- Ja, ja, es ist gut gegangen.
Aber der Weg dort unten rum
war die Hölle.
Das war die Bohne.
Ich bin in eine Spalte gefallen.
Ja, das waren
die Eisschollen auf dem See.
Ich kam nicht mehr raus.
- Das haben wir gesehen.
Nach über 10 Std.
erreicht auch Carmen das Ziel.
Eine Apfelschorle und keine Cola,
das ist toll.
Ist das gut?
- Das ist super.
(Alle) Bravo! Gratuliere!
Wir sind auch erst
vor 2 Min. angekommen.
Ja, sie haben
kaum ihre Schuhe ausgezogen.
Es war wie das Leiterspiel.
Ein Feld vorwärts
und wieder zwei Felder zurück.
* Fröhliche Handorgelklänge *
Die Hütte ist voll, rund 120
Tourenfahrer sind an diesem Tag
Ende April auf der Haute Route
unterwegs - von Hütte zu Hütte.
Gleichzeitig am gleichen Ort.
Noch 900 Höhenmeter mit Fellen.
Wir haben eine sehr schnelle Gruppe
und eine schnelle Gruppe.
* Sphärischer Jodel *
Bereits um 5 Uhr geht es
weiter, der Wind hat zugelegt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die Etappe
beginnt in der Cabane des Dix.
Es folgt der Aufstieg
über den Col de la Serpentine
auf die Pigne d'Arolla
auf fast 4'000 m.
Hinunter über den Col de l'Evêque
ins Bivouac de Bouquetins.
Wieder muss die Gruppe
eine achtstündige Tour
mit über 14 km und
1'500 Höhenmetern bewältigen.
Wir steigen noch kurz hier hoch.
Die gestrige Tour
hat Spuren hinterlassen.
Carmen startet mit Schmerzen.
Ja, jetzt zieht es.
Beim Runterfahren schmerzt es.
Blasen?
- Ja, Blasen hinten am Fuss.
Blasen rund um die Ferse herum.
Hast du mehr als eine Blase?
Ja, auf beiden Seiten:
eine mehrfache Angelegenheit.
Erst war es nur eine kleine Blase
auf der einen Seite,
das ging noch.
Aber jetzt haben sich die Blasen
etwas Platz verschafft.
Das Wetter ist noch gut, doch
die Schlechtwetterfront rückt näher.
Eigentlich war sie bereits
für den heutigen Tag angekündigt.
Es ist Hochsaison
auf der Haute Route.
Wie heute sind im Frühling täglich
Skitourengänger aus der ganzen Welt
in Gruppen unterwegs,
um sich ihren Traum zu erfüllen.
Steil bergauf
auf dem vereisten Gletscher,
mit Harscheisen,
den Steighilfen an den Ski,
geht es auf den Col de la Serpentine.
Hier sehen wir das Matterhorn.
Dann ein Stopp, vor dem
heikelsten Stück des Aufstiegs.
Wir nehmen das Flachstück,
dann machen wir zwei Seilschaften:
Fünf und fünf - und dort hinten oben
wird es schön flach.
Wird es steil?
- Ja, der erste Teil geht noch,
aber wenn man um die Ecke
in die Sonne kommt,
wenn dort
mit den Ski etwas passiert,
ist man schnell in Arolla unten.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Steil fällt eine Wand
aus Fels und Eis Richtung Norden ab.
Darüber der vereiste Steilhang
zur Pigne d'Arolla,
eine kritische Schlüsselstelle.
Das Gelände fällt ab.
Wenn jemand abrutscht,
müssen wir ihn halten können.
Kannst du fünf halten?
Ja, wenn ich aufpasse schon.
Wenn wir nahe zusammenbleiben,
schaffe ich das.
Vielleicht nicht gerade dort,
wo es senkrecht runtergeht,
aber mit dem Pickel schaffe ich das.
Sie würde auch reagieren,
um mit dem Pickel zu bremsen.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Ralph und David
haben die Gruppe geteilt.
Am Seil und auf Steigeisen
geht es über den vereisten Steilhang.
Der Wind hat zugelegt. Es ist kalt.
Vorboten der Schlechtwetterfront.
Wie nahe Leben und Tod auf einer
solchen Tour beieinander liegen,
zeigt sich zwei Tage später, als
eine andere Gruppe an dieser Stelle
in einen Sturm gerät,
die Orientierung verliert
und sieben Personen
in der Kälte ums Leben kommen.
So schnell sich
die Verhältnisse ändern können,
so gross ist auch
die Verantwortung der Bergführer
gegenüber ihren Gästen,
die ihnen vertrauen.
Wir können uns hier versammeln.
Nach dem gestrigen Tag
habe ich befürchtet,
dass es heute viel schwieriger wird,
hier hochzukommen,
aber es ging ganz gut.
Schwieriger von der Kondition her?
- Ja.
Ich konnte mich gut erholen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Es brennt einfach ein bisschen,
das merke ich.
Wenn ich in den Schuh schlüpfe,
die Ski an- und abschnalle,
schmerzt es, ja.
Aber nicht mehr so stark
wie ganz am Anfang.
Es folgen die letzten Schritte
auf die Pigne d'Arolla,
mit 3'790 m das Dach der Tour.
Bei guten Bedingungen
haben es alle geschafft,
auch Paul,
der vor 50 Jahren zum ersten Mal
genau an diesem Punkt stand.
Gratuliere.
- Gratuliere.
Gratuliere. Du bist tipptopp
gelaufen, schön regelmässig.
Das ist irrsinnig.
Ich glaubte nicht daran,
dass ich es hier hochschaffe,
aber es ist herrlich.
Wieder nur eine kurze Rast,
denn am Horizont
kommen die Wolken immer näher.
Gehen wir jetzt wieder los?
- Ja.
* Fröhliche Handorgelklänge *
Und endlich wieder eine Abfahrt,
bevor es
in die nächste Steigung geht.
Carmen, hast du Zeit,
dem Wolkenspiel zuzuschauen?
Oder getraust du dich nicht mehr,
dich umzuschauen?
Läufst du auf dem Zahnfleisch?
Nein, ich laufe einfach mein Tempo.
- Das ist gut.
Geht es mit den Schmerzen?
Kann ich dir helfen?- Nein.
Soll ich vor dir laufen
und das Tempo übernehmen?
Das Tempo übernehmen?
Ich laufe vor dir und versuche,
das Tempo anzupassen.
Wir sind zügig unterwegs.
Das kommt gut.
Im Flachen schon, ja.
Nebel kommt auf, es stürmt.
Doch David kennt den Weg.
So, bravo, tipptopp.
Ist bei dir alles gut, Paul?
- Ja, ja.
Wegen dem Nebel fahren wir
jetzt schon hier Richtung Biwak.
Es folgt ein kleiner Aufstieg,
dann kommen wir gemütlich zum Biwak.
Wir müssen noch Schnee schmelzen,
damit wir Wasser fürs Kochen haben.
Es gibt noch Arbeit
heute Nachmittag.
Danke fürs Führen.
Carmen, tipptopp.
- Ja, sie macht das gut.
Ein Tick langsamer,
aber immer flüssig gelaufen.
Ich habe schwere Beine.
Ihr Ziel heute
ist das Bivouac de Bouqetins,
ein Biwak,
das hoch über dem Gletscher liegt.
Es ist nicht bewirtschaftet,
verfügt aber über
eine Kochgelegenheit mit Brennholz.
Für eine letzte Nacht
weg vom Rummel der grossen Hütten.
Und nur noch einen Tag entfernt vom
Ziel - dem Matterhorn und Zermatt.
Schau dir das an!
Das ist ja voll geil.
Cool, nicht wahr?
Ich machte mich
auf das Schlimmste gefasst,
dabei ist es so geil.
Es hat viel Platz,
sonst ist es jeweils viel enger.
Warte nur, bis alle hier sind.
Dann ist es nicht mehr so einfach,
sich hier zu bewegen.
Das sieht gut aus.
Schön.
Komm in die warme Stube.
Es hat Jasskarten - hat jemand Lust?
Ich weiss nicht, ob es
einen Break mit den Handys gab.
Gab es einen?
- Zuerst hatte ich keinen Empfang.
Jetzt schreibe ich kurz nach Hause,
wo wir sind.
Hast du keine Entscheidungen
getroffen, die SMS nur gelesen?
Nur gelesen, ja.
- Bravo.
Wieso liest du die SMS, wenn du
keine Entscheidungen triffst?
Dann bin ich informiert und
muss am Samstag weniger aufarbeiten.
Machst du sonst Ferien,
ohne deine SMS anzuschauen?
Aber nicht, weil ich nicht kann,
sondern weil ich nicht will.
Wenn ich eine Woche weg bin
und zwei Tage brauche, um die ange-
sammelten 150 E-Mails abzuarbeiten,
ist der Ferieneffekt dahin.
Heute fand ich heraus, dass es
wirklich viel ... also für mich ...
Das ist jetzt
nicht so wissenschaftlich,
das betrifft nur mich.
Es ist sowohl motivierender
wie auch befriedigender für mich,
auf einen Gipfel zu steigen
als auf einen Pass.
Das finde ich noch spannend.
Heute konnte ich wirklich sagen:
Sowohl gestern Rosablanche
wie auch heute Pigne du ...
Ich habe schon wieder
den Namen vergessen.
Pigne d'Arolla
- Pigne d'Arolla - fast.
Es geht viel einfacher,
wenn ich sehe,
dass dort oben
der höchste Punkt ist,
dann kann es eh nicht weiter gehen.
Aber bei einem Pass
ist man nie sicher,
ob hinter jenem Hügel
noch ein weiterer Hügel kommt.
Es hat noch eine weitere Komponente:
Alle Menschen wollen oben sein.
Das ist doch etwas,
das uns eingepflanzt ist.
Auf einem Pass
bist du nicht zuoberst,
hast den Kern noch nicht erreicht.
Ich mag Pässe lieber als Gipfel.
Warum?
- Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ist mir sympathischer,
weil ich nicht gerne runterschaue.
Ja, das muss ich sagen.
Abgiessen?
- Warte, das mache ich.
Ich bin zuständig für diesen
blöden Griff. Geht mir aus dem Weg!
Hauswirtschaftslehrerin Yolanda über-
nimmt gemeinsam mit Ralph das Kochen.
Das reicht weit.
A table, à table!
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Guten Appetit!
- Danke fürs Kochen, Yolanda.
Kurz vor dem Ziel
noch einmal ein Moment für alle,
darüber nachzudenken,
warum man sich den Traum
Haute Route erfüllen wollte.
Ich hatte
eine sehr schöne Skitourenwoche.
Ich hatte eine sehr schöne
Skitourenwoche mit euch zusammen.
Wir waren eine wunderbare Truppe.
Auch das Wetter hat mega mitgemacht,
die Landschaft war einmalig.
Das war etwas sehr Spezielles.
Die Sache mit dem Mutigwerden.
Ist das bei dir passiert?
Ein Schrittchen weit,
aber es liegt noch viel vor mir.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig
auf meine Buben zu Hause.
Meine Mutter
schickte mir heute noch ein Foto,
wie sie am Spielen sind.
Mir kommt es vor, als wären sie
in dieser Woche enorm gewachsen.
Es sind schon wieder grössere Buben.
Es ist mir bewusst,
dass ich kaum mehr eine derart
grosse Tour mit ihr machen werde.
Wir werden wohl noch
Tages- oder Zweitagestouren machen,
aber sicher nicht mehr - das kann
ich mir vorstellen - eine Woche.
Ich kam bei dieser Tour
ziemlich an meine Grenzen.
Das muss ich erkennen.
Körperlich war es etwas anstrengend,
aber ich denke,
für den Kopf war es Gold wert.
Ich werde es
v.a. nächste Woche merken.
Im positiven oder negativen Sinn?
Nein, ich denke, ich werde
mit neuer Frische und Motivation
an etwas herangehen, über das
ich mir Gedanken machen muss
nach dieser Woche, eigentlich.
Und natürlich diese Eindrücke.
Landschaftlich war es wunderschön.
Ich musste wirklich
eine Woche lang wenig nachdenken.
Das war sehr erholsam.
Keine unlösbaren Probleme im Kopf
zu wälzen, habe ich sehr genossen.
Ich habe auch wirklich nichts getan.
Ich dachte,
vielleicht kommt es irgendwann,
dass irgendetwas,
das mich gerade beschäftigt,
im Kopf zu drehen beginnt,
aber das war nie der Fall.
Die Firma gibt es noch.
Ich glaube, alle sind noch dort.
Und so gesehen
hat es gut funktioniert.
Es freut mich einerseits,
dass der Betrieb letztlich nicht
von einer Einzelperson abhängig ist.
Andererseits hat mich sehr gefreut,
die Haute Route
endlich einmal machen zu können,
die ich schon immer
gerne einmal machen wollte.
Das mit euch zusammen zu machen,
war super.
Du hattest verschiedene Wünsche.
Einerseits wolltest du
die Haute Route machen,
andererseits hat die Geschichte
deiner Mutter mitgeschwungen,
die Erinnerung an sie.
Wie stark war das präsent?
Ich dachte, die Erinnerungen und
alles würden wesentlich mehr sein.
Ich war ...
Ich war schlichtweg zu stark
mit mir selbst beschäftigt,
auch mit allem rundherum.
So wurde es gar
nicht zu einem Thema,
ausser auf Rosablanche, von wo ich
zwei, drei Steine mitgenommen habe,
die ich auf ihr Grab legen werde,
aber mehr nicht.
Mit welchem Gefühl
kehrst du in den Alltag zurück?
Mit welchem Gefühl?
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Alles ist
so schnell vorbeigegangen.
Also, ja ... Ich hatte
viele verschiedene Eindrücke.
Ich kann es kaum genau benennen.
Vieles ist viel besser gelaufen,
als ich gedacht habe.
Ja, ich kann es
gar nicht so genau fassen.
* Sphärischer Frauengesang *
Noch einmal um 5 Uhr aufstehen,
noch einmal im Schein der Stirnlampen
auf dem gefrorenen Gletscher
zum letzten Aufstieg fahren.
Die Haute Route ist auch
eine Geschichte über Menschen,
die sich vorher nicht kannten
und an ihre Grenzen kamen.
Die lernten,
mit Steigeisen zu klettern,
sich zu überwinden und gemeinsam
als Gruppe an das Ziel zu glauben.
Das war die letzte Mauer,
jetzt folgt der Endspurt.
Hier fahren wir
200 Höhenmeter hinunter,
dann steigen wir mit den Fellen
noch 2 Std. hoch.
Erkennst du deinen Berg?
Ich war schon lange nicht mehr
so froh, diesen Hügel zu sehen.
* Jauchzer *
Daniel, ich danke dir vielmals,
äh, David, ich danke dir vielmals.
David, danke vielmals.
Das war schön.
Ja, das war so schön,
danke vielmals.
Fränzi.
- Merci. Danke.
Dominique.
- David, danke vielmals.- Merci.
Super.
Daniel, danke dir vielmals.
Das war super.
Das habe ich gerne getan.
- Sicher?
In diesem Alter möchte ich
auch noch so gut laufen wie du.
Jetzt kommen mir noch die Tränen.
Ich ziehe die Brille nicht ab.
* Sentimentale Trompetenklänge *
Gratuliere!
Schön. Stimmung!
Und so endet dieses Abenteuer
nach sechs Tagen in den hohen Bergen
mit Blick auf das Matterhorn.
Bevor sie hinunterfahren,
zurück in den Alltag.
Denn manchmal ist es an der Zeit,
das zu tun, wovon man geträumt hat,
und dem Leben
ein neues Kapitel hinzuzufügen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Michaela Hoss - 2020